ثماني شحنات وواحدة من
أخطر الأماكن في أوكرانيا ،
نحن مع مؤسسة Howard G Buffett
في بلدة خط المواجهة حيث
يقول الروس إن الجيش الأوكراني
يحاول اختراق دفاعاتهم
بقذائف المدفعية وقذائف الهاون المستمرة التي
تقود السكان تحت الأرض
النزول إلى الطابق السفلي في
الطابق السفلي نظرًا لحدوث
زيادة واضحة في القصف ، وبينما لا يمكنك
حقًا رؤية الهجوم المضاد
للأوكرانيين هنا ، يمكنك بالتأكيد سماعه
والشعور به أيضًا
في قائدة المأوى في الطابق السفلي فاليري
كوبوشكا تقدم المساعدة  صناديق
للمقيمين معظمهم من كبار السن
أصيبوا بصدمات نفسية ولكن مرنًا ،
إنه أمر خطير للغاية هنا ، لكنني اعتدت
على ذلك ، أخبرني أولغا البالغة من العمر 72 عامًا أنه يمكنني
بالفعل التمييز بين الصواريخ من خلال
صوتها.
يمكن أن ينجح الهجوم ، نعم ،
أعلم عن الهجوم المضاد ، كما تقول ،
إننا سنكون أقرب إلى النصر ،
وسيدفعهم إلى الوراء خطوة بخطوة حتى يتم
طردهم حتى يكون هناك
نصر كامل لأوكرانيا ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي يبدو أن الذهاب
صعب على  الأوكرانيون بينما
لم تعترف كييف بالعمليات الهجومية الكبرى
هنا ، قال مسؤولون أمريكيون لشبكة CNN إن
الجيش الأوكراني يواجه
مقاومة روسية شديدة في هذا الفيديو الروسي الذي
يزعم أنه يظهر عمودًا من
الدروع التي تبرع بها الغرب ضربته قوات موسكو ،
وقد جعل تصاعد القتال الأمر
شبه مستحيل  للحصول على مساعدة في فاليري ،
أخبرني أنها واحدة من أخطر
المناطق في المنطقة الباريسية
أو إيجيبتشا ، لقد
قصفت 24 ساعة 24 ساعة
ولكن يجب عليهم تقديم المساعدة حتى لهذين
الضعفاء حتى يصلوا إلى
نقطة التوزيع الجدة بوليا كما هي  معروفة هنا
بالكاد تستطيع المشي وترفض أن يتم
إخلائها من منزلها الصغير حتى مع استمرار
القذائف في تساقط مصيرها ،
تقول إنها الآن في يد الله ، فهل
سننجو أم لا ، تسأل أنك ما
زلت صغيرة ، قد يعطيك الله الصحة
ويساعدك على ذلك  البقاء على قيد الحياة في هذه الحرب ، من
الصعب جدًا على كبار السن ،
من الواضح جدًا أن الرئيس زيلينسكي
يستمتع ببعض ردود الفعل التي تحدثها
العمليات العسكرية الأخيرة التي تم تنفيذها
هنا داخل أوكرانيا ضد الروس
في الكرملين مع
ادعاء فلاديمير بوتين أن
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني  بدأ الأمر وأنه
فشل مع
رد الرئيس زيلينسكي على
هذا النحو ،
فمن المثير للاهتمام أن بوتين كان يتحدث
عن هجومنا المضاد ، من
المهم أن تشعر روسيا دائمًا أنه
لم يتبق لها الكثير من الوقت
الآن في القول إنه يريد
الرئيس الروسي  والروس بالفعل على نطاق أوسع
ليشعروا بنتائج
هجوم مضاد يتحدث عن
شيئين أولهما الألم العسكري
الذي يريد أن يتسبب فيه ولكن أيضًا
عدم الاستقرار السياسي وهما
مرتبطان ارتباطًا وثيقًا جدًا بسبب وجود
احتكاكات خطيرة جدًا  داخل
هياكل القيادة داخل
مناطق قيادة الخط الأمامي على الجبهة الشرقية على
وجه الخصوص مع مجموعة مرتزقة فاجنر التي
تنتقد بشكل صريح
الوحدات المجاورة وخاصة اللواء الميكانيكي الثاني والسبعين
في نقطة واحدة حتى على ما يبدو
القبض على ذلك القائد وتعريضه
لجولة مذلة من التعذيب في
الأعلى.  تمكن الأوكرانيون من
اختراق جزء كبير من
الأراضي الواقعة إلى الجنوب الشرقي من باكموت وهم
يستولون على المناطق التي فقدوها في وقت
سابق من هذا العام فيما كان في ذلك
الوقت تقدمًا روسيًا سريعًا للغاية
يتم عكسه الآن على تلك الجبهة وهم
يقاضون  هذا هو الأوكرانيون
يلاحقون عددًا كبيرًا من
الهجمات الاستقصائية على طول الخط الأمامي
الممتد من مدينة زاباريسيا الخاضعة للسيطرة الأوكرانية
إلى المدينة الصحية الروسية
في المستقبل ، الكثير من محاولات حجم الشركة
لاختراق هذا
الخط الدفاعي الروسي الكبير جدًا أه
نتج عنها بوضوح  الإصابات بين
الأوكرانيين في خسائر بعض
المركبات وخاصة بعض
مركبات برادلي القتالية ومركبات أخرى تابعة للجيش
تم توفيرها من قبل
شركاء آخرين في الناتو من الولايات المتحدة ، وهذا أمر لا مفر منه
ولكن تم وصفه لشبكة CNN من قبل الضباط
على الأرض على أنه استطلاع بالقوة
بدلاً من كونه
مضادًا مباشرًا  - هجومية ولكن كل هذا يضيف
إلى محاولة لمواصلة زعزعة
استقرار الروس عسكريا
وسياسيا
سام كايلي سي إن إن وكييف